in this episode of cloud performance
atlas we help a food image sharing
service get performance back on track
with custom images like your meals in 30
minutes or less then stay tuned last
episode we got a chance to work with the
foodie pix team who make a social
network that only allows you to share
pictures of food no text no audio no
emoji just a picture of food and the geo
locate a gov
their application uses compute engine
instances to process and store the
uploaded images the issue that they've
seen is that their instance boot time is
through the roof and causing latency
issues when heavy load is on their
system
now we've already profiled the startup
time stages as well as a bunch of random
configurations and we're able to clearly
eliminate the instance boot process
chose an image and underlying serving
architecture as potential bottlenecks
for performance which means it was time
to start digging into the code running
on the instance to find the problem to
do this we take a look at the startup
script that foody pics was using once a
new instance was created their very
first step of their app was to execute a
startup script which installed various
services and code libraries that would
allow the instance to function and be
accessible externally their script was
significantly more complex but it
generally looks something like this
clearly though we needed to figure out
what stage of this script was causing
the performance burden now profiling a
startup script is a weird exercise a how
do we get the timing data and be how do
we return that so that we can test it
later for the first problem I'm working
in Linux and dealing with bash scripts
so the seconds command works just fine
wrapping it around each one of the
sections in the script for the second
problem of reporting the data there's
lots of options here chances are that
you've got code that already takes
advantage of powerful tool systems like
stats D or Brubeck but for my purposes
that would require pulling down yet
another package not to mention the time
required in starting those services
before I'd be able to use them so I'll
skip that for now on the other hand the
stackdriver custom metrics api might
work see all GCE instances come
pre-installed with access to write to
this API so that would get rid of the
need to bring down new packages or host
complex backends sadly though writing to
the API requires some complexity namely
authentication which I'm not really to
put for
effort into right now so we'll skip that
for this case I did something much more
hacked astok store the timings in a file
and serve them as a new endpoint this
allowed me to pull the endpoint from an
external location and get back my data
without too much heavy lifting here is a
graph showing the timings for each
section as 100 iterations of timing the
startup script it's clear to see in the
graft at the time of per stage of the
startup script doesn't fluctuate too
much between tests it's somewhere
between 60 and 75 seconds no one staged
clearly stands out as a performance
problem really it's the aggregation of
all the stages that's creating an issue
doing some more digging with the foodie
pics CTO it became clear that they only
updated those scripts about once or
twice a month at this point so the
content they were pulling down was
mostly static which pointed almost
immediately to their problem see each
time a new instance is spun up they're
pulling down almost identical content
that changes on maybe a monthly basis
they're basically wasting a minute of
cold boot time to do the same thing over
and over and over again which means we
can leverage custom images a custom
image or image snapshot is basically a
snapshot of the host disk information
after everything has already been
installed when a target VM is booted the
image information is copied right to the
hard drive
no need to go grab all that data one at
a time and install thousands of files
from the net as soon as you boot up the
new instance you're just paying for the
performance cost of installing the image
itself for footie pics this was a huge
performance improvements they were able
to make a custom image with most of the
big packages installed but still allowed
a small startup script that pulled down
the server front-end code the result was
moving from a boot time in minutes down
to one measured in sub seconds and just
a note even though we're using a custom
image the boot phase of installing their
image really didn't fluctuate much which
is fantastic considering that we're not
only installing our core operating
system but also a bunch of other
software which was previously pulled
down via Network commands the footie
pics team ran into a very common problem
for most developers once you reach a
certain level of complexity in your
startup scripts the cold boot time of
your application starts to suffer at
which point it's a
great idea to consider using custom
images to bring down your boot time to
something normal so if you're interested
in more cloud performance goodness make
sure to check out the rest of our videos
and remember when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts